right superlatives time chris what do
you have coming out of the
uh conference championship round well
i'm gonna go with uh the dick vermeel
award all right and that's because it's
andy reid i mean andy reid goes to and
ends up being what this is the second
longest gap in between super bowl
appearances
uh between for a head coach other than
dick vermeel who of course had the
longest one when he went to philadelphia
eagles and then you know what was it 20
18 years 19 years later does it with the
st louis rams at the time i mean this is
special i mean come on andy reid
by far the greatest coach ever to not
win a super bowl uh it's oh but grant
would take issues okay you're right i'll
throw you're right he's in that
conversation as well he's he's by far
the greatest coach of this era i should
say to have not won a super bowl and to
now get to his second one with the
second organization and ever since he
switched from green to red this team in
the red has been winning and relevant
and he's done that and then had the
genius of course to evaluate a guy like
patrick mahomes make the move to go get
him and that has changed their
organization into
from being a playoff contender to now oh
we're in the super bowl conversation
every year and uh kudos to andy reid
really really happy for him
and the genius came from the reality
that he knew he had to get to number 10
to get patrick mahomes because he
recognized that what he saw in mahomes a
guy named sean payton saw in my homes
and payton i firmly believe was ready to
take my homes if he had been there at
number 11 back in 2017 also marv levy a
pretty good coach to have never won a
super bowl he took the bills there four
straight times didn't get it done but
the fact that they were able to go back
again again again and again uh
incredible work by marv levy and andy
reid is going to be a sentimental
favorite this time around uh that's
going to be one of the factors that
plays in the chief's favor as casual
fans decide who they want to win he's
paid his dues he's been through a lot
personally 20 years he's given to the
sport as a head coach years beyond that
as an assistant and yeah it feels like
he deserves it right yeah uh he's earned
it to get to this point and it's time
for him to get that icing on top of the
cake but uh you know the 49ers gonna
have something to say about it chris and
kyle shanahan in his first crack at a
super bowl
may realize just like dan marino did 34
years ago against the 49ers just because
you got there doesn't mean you're ever
getting back no so you better go try to
win it while you're there all right my
first superlative is going to be the uh
um
the bob griese award i had to remember
the guy's name bob griese hall of fame
quarterback it goes to jimmy garoppolo
consider this the two super bowls that
bob griese won
he threw 11 passes in the first one and
seven passes in the second one yes when
the dolphins beat my minnesota vikings
as you would say chris in super bowl
eight the first super bowl i ever
watched wired a wire bob greasy only had
to throw the ball seven times completing
six because larry zonka ran over
everyone same thing played out yesterday
jimmy garoppolo doesn't have to do
anything because raheem mostert ran over
everyone over and over and over again so
it was six completions eight attempts 77
yards for jimmy garoppolo those aren't
highlights we're showing folks those are
every pass completed by jimmy garoppolo
in the entire game you know well it's
remarkable and again it just shows that
like you know hey
you don't like it doesn't always have to
be about the quarterback oh we got to
have the franchise quarterback and we
don't have him there's no way we can win
the game no there's other ways to win a
game and you've seen that the 49ers are
the perfect example i mean jimmy
garolopolo is not one of the five we're
not one of the 10 best quarterbacks in
the sport right now he's not but he's
good and he has a great team around him
and it just shows you can win a super
bowl that way doesn't always have to
have like tom brady or russell wilson or
aaron rodgers to go to the super bowl
you know you can do it other ways and
it's just phenomenal the way they did it
he made a few throws on the first drive
of the game right mike got them some
momentum and then it was like shanahan
was like wait we can run with them and
will let's just keep doing it and if it
ain't broke don't fix it so i give them
a lot of credit there my next let me ask
you this let me ask you this let me ask
you this though yeah because here's
something i'm wrestling with and we're
going to talk about it more later in the
week but you know if i'm a 49ers fan i
i'm going to ask at some point why are
we paying this guy twenty seven and a
half million dollars a year from okay
use him right does his presence does the
threat of the fact that we could use him
if we need to does that justify paying
him that money i mean could you put nick
mullins or cj beathard out there and
have the same result with this with this
rushing attack or do you need a
quarterback who at least keeps you from
putting 11 guys at the line of scrimmage
in order to allow the running game to go
well you know again this is not apples
to apples but jimmy garoppolo certainly
showed he's more important than a cj
beathard or nick mullen they they
couldn't win with those guys and you
know they had a lot of games that were
winnable with both of those quarterbacks
where they couldn't make the big throw
in the third or fourth quarter to get
them over the hump or get the next first
down to keep a drive going they wouldn't
have to make one yesterday no they
didn't have to do it are they going to
put any of those yesterday the point is
he did it a number of times during the
regular season to get them to this point
yesterday where that happened i think
that's where you got to look at it and
he answered the questions yeah i mean
yeah he's not desean watson or mahomes
or roger he's not one of those guys he's
not but he's still smart he still
doesn't like bat an eye in clutch
situations he proved that to us this
year is he perfect do we want to sit
here and go oh they can if they need him
to carry the squad he'll do it no i
don't think he can do that you're right
but they don't ask him to do that and he
does give their team some sort of lift
you can certainly tell he's loved by the
team that's one thing you know right he
walks into the stadium with joe staley
and mcglinchey every week on when they
have home games i mean your tight end
doesn't wear a t-shirt you know with you
dressed in spandex showing your chest if
he doesn't really love you and have
respect and you have that great
relationship to know you can do that and
embarrass him you know and the podium on
a post game after the nfc championship
game so i think that shows you a lot to
maybe the person and the leadership he
has in the locker room and the guys
rally around him a little bit
all right what's your next one um like
father like son you ever see that movie
like father like son i can't remember if
like father like son was the one with
dudley moore and kirk cameron or it was
the one with fred savage and i can't
remember the father's name i always get
vice versa and lot like father like son
uh confused but like father like son
goes to kyle shanahan i mean come on the
father was famous for his running attack
and the shanahan being a brilliant
offensive schemer to expose any
defensive scheme and kyle shanahan like
father like son he is that and like
father like son he's going to the super
bowl too and oddly enough going to the
super bowl in miami where his dad won
his last super bowl with the broncos
beating the atlanta falcons now kyle
shanahan gets to go back to that same
place you know as a grown man and a head
coach himself and brings the 49ers there
uh just an amazing story you know you
know the shanahan's have reached like
football royalty with this now you know
i know there's the mannings but then you
know you got to look at the shanahan
family as kind of being one of those
families up towards the top of that
conversation as well with with the longs
and whoever else
well and especially from a coaching
perspective right you get a super bowl
win for father and son unprecedented and
look when patrick mahomes was taking the
league by storm in 2018 one of the
explanations for his comfort
his ease of transition to the nfl stage
was that he'd been around it his whole
life because his dad played major league
baseball and he wasn't freaked out by
the moment the magnitude the pressure
he'd seen it all and i think kyle
hanging around when he was a kid right
now 25 years ago when he'd been 15 years
old when the 49ers won the super bowl
and mike was the offensive coordinator
and then a few years after that a couple
of back-to-back super bowl wins for the
denver broncos and kyle's around that i
i think that uh that that's the thing
that's impressing me about kyle is
he knows he has a great team they've put
together a special team that can run the
systems he wants right and he just
trusts them to go do it exactly right
yeah the hard work's already been done
on game day let's just go do what we're
supposed to do we found the guys who can
do it we trust you to do it and we're
going to go do it and i'm not going to
get in the way of it that that's where
you know that's where any nfl team
should work to have what shanahan and
lynch have
this is what happens when you have a gm
a front office on the same page as the
head coach you get exactly what you're
explaining yeah you get talent but
talent that fits within the scheme and
then when you have a scheme that knows
how to utilize that talent and it all
comes together you have super bowl
appearances and that's what you have and
you're right shanahan's he's been
molding himself for this for a long long
time go back and watch the nfl films
packers versus broncos super bowl he's
sitting there holding the wires for his
dad behind him so you're right he's
always been around it he was always
getting ready for this moment he's
handled it with you know what do i want
to say flying stars is that what the
hell that phrase is uh no maybe blind
kelly's buying customers that's right
color stars you know it's all happy
that's what i'm talking about
[Laughter]
all right one more for me real quick
it's the eduardo carroccio award you
know who eduardo no i do not
he is the bull fighter the that elaine
bennis made up uh to try to impress
somebody once upon a time i remember
that's her boyfriend eduardo
uh matador um that's patrick mahomes
at the goal line because he was the
matador and a couple of titans defensive
backs were the bulls uh look as you
would say i've checked the rule book
you're allowed to tackle the quarterback
it was amazing to me that as patron
homes at the tail end of that 27 yard
touchdown run a phenomenal effort by him
the head fake that sprung him the
ability to keep his feet in bounds but
then when he gets inside the five and he
is fair game yeah he is a running back
he is no different than damien williams
derrick henry any other running back on
the field that day watch the two
defensive backs i don't know what 37 is
doing it's like tremendously trying to
pull the ball out yeah right but the
train i don't know who 37 is off the top
of my head watch 37 near the goal line
you tell me what the hell this guy is
trying to do chris watch it right here
what is that i don't know what that is
you're right i mean he's like he just
threw a shoulder out there thinking he
might hit him hard enough to jar the
ball loose i don't know what he was
doing there either but uh yeah it was
poor tackling there i mean again make a
tackle see if kansas city can score and
once they get inside the five yard line
that was a huge moment and just a great
play by a great player
we give patreon homes a red cape to go
along with that red jersey because he
was able to keep
the bulls at bay on that run and that
was just one of those moments where
everybody made it 21-17 chiefs lead at
halftime and he just felt at that point
that the chiefs were going to punch
their ticket to super bowl
54
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports